coin versus gold which one is better  obviously Bitcoin because gold can be  confiscated since the dawn of time Kings  and governments have just been  confiscating people's goals whether at  Roosevelt whether it's the Nazis with  Bitcoin nobody needs to even know that  you own it due to the very high level of  anonymity that it enabled with gold of  course you can leave it under your  mattress or in your house but that can  be cease and confiscated usually people  tend to leave their gold in a vault  which you have to give your customer  name and so again it can be seized if  you say the wrong thing on social media  or if you're protesting body autonomy  like they try to do in Canada well then  they can just come take your gold you  cannot take somebody's Bitcoin